This episode is supported by (Himes)
With more than three million Americans using steroid, the desire to amplify the muscles is high
But what happens to your body when taking steroids? Are there significant risks to performance improvement real estate?
Every time you lift weights in the club, your muscles are torn
But the body heals by forming new protein filaments to repair muscle fibers.
Over time, the number and density of these threads increases
In the end, if the protein synthesis rate is higher than the fraction, your muscles will grow
The hormone testosterone regulates the degree of growth, by increasing protein synthesis
Which is behind the increase of muscle in men for women, because of higher levels of testosterone
Steroid is any compound of four specific rings of carbon
Steroid actually contains some chemical compounds that can be used to treat heat and headaches
And even sex hormones such as estrogen and testosterone.
But the type of steroids that we will focus on is the one that mimics natural testosterone to improve performance
Which is used by more than 15% of athletes.
Within the first day of steroid use, your gene expression will begin to change.
Steroid enters cells easily and binds to the androgen receptor
At this stage it can move to the nucleus and adhere to the DNA
Which will do hundreds of genes that increase protein synthesis and reduce its fracture.
Steroid users can have three to five times the nuclei in some muscle cells.
Steroid can also stop the differentiation of fatty stem cells
And reduce the proportion of fat in the body.
Within days, the volume and strength of your muscles will increase rapidly
While keeping your muscle fibers from rupturing, which makes steroids ideal for exercise and recovery
But if you continue to use it, your behavior will begin to change
And the presence of steroid receptors in parts of the central nervous system
Such as the anterior brain, pituitary gland and hypothalamus, steroid can lead to a rage revolution
A study of athletes taking steroids showed that 20 percent had higher levels of mania and depression than non-users
The mice that were given steroids over 10 weeks became more aggressive against other mice in the same cage
Male rats have also become more controlled and willing to compete for sex with female rats
But this desire for sex may not mean better sexual performance.
For female users
Steroids can interfere with the cycle of ejaculation and reduce libido.
A male condition may also occur in women by gaining male voice and increasing the growth of facial and body hair.
Male users may experience abnormalities in the sperm cells and lack of sperm count.
Steroids also reduce the normal production of hormones necessary to maintain testicular size
Which means the contraction of the testicles.
As most steroids use periods of use and stop doses
The normal levels of testosterone may be low at times
Causing erectile dysfunction and reducing libido in males.
It also increases the thoracic tissue to 40% of male users while breaking up steroids into estradiol
Which stimulates the growth of breast tissue.
Finally, steroid can cause high levels of acne among half the users
And increases the risk of heart disease and stroke
Yes, steroid will make you swell quickly and improve your athletic performance
But like most things, it brings with it many risks and side effects that can happen to you.
We would like to thank Himes for supporting this video.
(HIMZ) is a company that makes it easier for men to deal with problems
They can be embarrassing, such as hair loss, erectile dysfunction, and skin problems.
Himes offers recommendations
Personal advice from doctors
And everything
Confidential and all treatments have been scientifically tested
In addition, all of their products are cheap because they do not use any brand names
It is connected to your door.
You can express your support for our program by visiting forhims.com/asaphair
For an integrated hair story
For $ 5, a good deal.
With time and our friends and our time, we are talking a lot about
Hair loss so having an integrated kit like this is a way
Ideal for getting started.
So friends, let's take care of ourselves and start it by going to forhims.com/asaphair
Subscribe to the channel and see you next week.
Translation team translated @Autrjim